[Music]
this is exactly what President Putin
didn't want to see a new flag raised at
NATO HQ
avoiding the expansion of this military
Alliance was one of the reasons Russia
gave for invading Ukraine ironically
that act of aggression is what triggered
Finland to join
President Putin
wanted to slam NATO's door shut
today we show the world that he failed
that aggression and intimidation do not
work
the Decades of being neutral Finn's now
firmly back NATO
with a strong capable military villains
new membership packs a punch
a point not lost on the Kremlin whose
defense minister warned it will take
countermeasures
membership will create a risk of
expanding the conflict he said but won't
affect the outcome of the Special
Operations
and it's easy to see why Russia is
worried
all of these countries are already in
NATO and if you add Finland you
basically double the NATO border with
Russia and reinforce this Eastern flank
add Sweden which is currently being
blocked by turkey and you can hold the
Baltic Sea like many on the Eastern
Front Poland Bears the scars of Soviet
atrocities
here they say finland's membership makes
all of its NATO neighbors safer a major
blow to Russia so Finland joining NATO
is a big step towards peace in Europe
because Finland joining NATO reduces the
possibility of Russia attacking another
European country
now this Alliance stands at 31 by the
end of the year it could be 32. Putin's
aggression has only strengthened his
enemy Siobhan Robbins Sky News Poland